oh my name is Mariana Blair I come from
friends and I would like to know how do
you succeed to discover the big man
Terry how did you succeed to to discover
these things and because I'm really
impressed so that's it thank you well hi
Marianne to tell you the truth I didn't
discover the big bang theory that honor
goes back to the 1920s when Edwin Hubble
discovered the galaxies are going away
from us at great speeds and a few years
before that when theorists predicted
this result based on Einstein's
equations so I didn't discover the
theory but it's been under test for a
long time the work that I did was to
test the theory by measuring the
primordial heat radiation this is heat
radiation that should still fill the
universe and is really quite bright but
was very difficult to measure so our job
with our cosmic background Explorer
satellite was to measure the heat of the
radiation see if it matches the
prediction of the theory very precisely
and in addition to see whether it's
equally bright in all directions so the
result was it matches up exactly with
what the predictions of the Big Bang
Theory say it should be